one thing that's not often discussed
about dopamine but is extremely
important to know that's a low dopamine
state which leads to shaky movements
challenges in speaking challenges in
particular in initiating movement also
experience drops in motivation and
affect meaning mood they tend to get
depressed and so on if ever you've
interacted with somebody who just
doesn't seem to have any Drive they've
given up or if you've interacted with
somebody who seems to have endless drive
and energy what you are looking at there
in those two circumstances is without
question a difference in the level of
dopamine circulating in their system
there will be other factors too but the
level of dopamine is the primary
determinant of how motivated we are how
excited we are how outward facing we are
and how willing we are to lean into life
and pursue things
foreign
does is dopamine really colors the
subjective experience of an activity to
make it more pleasureful to make it
something that you want more of today we
are going to talk all about dopamine and
what drives you to do the things that
you do and you'll come away with a deep
understanding of really what drives you
you will also Come Away with a lot of
tools how to leverage dopamine so that
you can sustain energy drive and
motivation for the things that are
important to you over long periods of
time there's a molecule in your brain
and body that when released tends to
make you look outside yourself pursue
things outside yourself and to Crave
things outside yourself but if ever you
felt lethargic and just lazy and you had
no motivation or drive that's a low
dopamine state if ever you felt really
excited motivated you are in a high
dopamine State dopamine is a universal
currency for moving us toward goals and
it's the way that you track pleasure
it's the way that you track success it's
the way that you track whether or not
you are doing well or doing poorly and
that is subjective but if your dopamine
is too low you will not feel motivated
if your dopamine is really high you will
feel motivated and if your dopamine is
somewhere in the middle how you feel
depends on whether or not you had higher
dopamine a few minutes ago or lower
dopamine this is important your
experience of life and your level of
motivation and drive depends on how much
dopamine you have relative to your
recent experience there are a lot of
myths about the molecule dopamine we
often hear about so-called dopamine hits
this is again something that's just not
accounted for in the simple language of
dopamine hits okay a simple way to
Envision dopamine hits is every time you
do something you like eat a piece of
chocolate dopamine hit you look at your
Instagram dopamine hit you see someone
you like dopamine hit you know all these
things described as dopamine hits
neglect the fact that if you scroll
social media and you see something you
really like dopamine hit sure there's an
increase in dopamine but then you get to
something else and you go not that
interesting however had you arrived at
that second thing first you might think
that it was really interesting if you
had arrived to that second Instagram
post three days later or four days later
you might find it extremely interesting
again how much dopamine you experience
from something depends on your Baseline
level of dopamine when you arrive there
and your previous dopamine Peaks okay
that's super important to understand
stand and it's completely neglected by
the general language of dopamine hits
this is why when you repeatedly engage
in something that you enjoy your
threshold for enjoyment goes up and up
and up the behavior that most of us are
familiar with of engaging in something
that we really enjoy going to a
restaurant that we absolutely love or
engaging in some way with some person
that we really really enjoy but if we
continue to engage in that behavior over
and over again it kind of loses its Edge
it starts to kind of feel less exciting
to us some of us experience that drop in
excitement more quickly and more
severely than others but everyone
experiences that to some extent you are
going to achieve or I should say
experience some sort of dopamine release
you found the reward that's great but
then it needs to return to some lower
level why well because if you just
stayed there you would never continue to
forage for more it doesn't just increase
your Baseline and then stay there it
goes back down and what's very important
to understand is that it does doesn't
just go back down to the level it was
before it goes down to a level below
what it was before you went out seeking
that thing please remember this when you
experience something or you crave
something really desirable really
exciting to you very pleasurable what
happens afterwards is your Baseline
level of dopamine drops okay so these
peaks in dopamine they influence how
much dopamine will generally be
circulating afterward and you might
think oh a big peak in dopamine after
that I'm gonna feel even better because
I just had this great event not the case
what actually happens is that your
Baseline level of dopamine drops so
dopamine is one of those things that you
don't want too high or too low for too
long it's all about staying in that
dynamic range and that's going to be
different for everybody so let's take a
look at some of the typical things that
people take and do and eat some are good
for us some are not good for us and
let's ask how much dopamine is increased
above Baseline chocolate chocolate will
increase your base line level of
dopamine 1.5 times okay so it's a pretty
substantial increase in dopamine it's
transient it goes away after a few
minutes or even a few seconds sex both
the pursuit of Sex and the act of sex
increases dopamine two times so it's a
doubling above Baseline nicotine in
particular nicotine that is smoked like
cigarettes and so forth increases
dopamine two and a half times above
Baseline so there's a peak that goes up
above Baseline two and a half times
higher the increase in dopamine from
nicotine is very short-lived exercise
now exercise will have a different
impact on the levels of dopamine
depending on how much somebody
subjectively enjoys that exercise so if
you're somebody who loves running
chances are it's going to increase your
levels of dopamine two times above your
Baseline people who dislike exercise
will achieve less dopamine increase or
no increase in dopamine from exercise
one that you might be wondering about is
caffeine does it increase dopamine well
a little bit caffeine will increase
dopamine to some extent but it is pretty
modest compared to the other things that
I described however regular ingestion of
caffeine increases upregulation of
certain dopamine receptors so caffeine
actually makes you able to experience
more of dopamine's effects there are
activities that we can do that will give
us healthy sustained increases in
dopamine first of all getting into cold
water can have tremendously beneficial
results on your neuromodulator systems
including dopamine but then what was
interesting is they observed that
dopamine levels started to rise somewhat
slowly and then continue to rise and
reach levels as high as 2.5 times above
Baseline the increase in dopamine from
cold water exposure of this kind was
comparable to what one sees from nicot
team except in this case it wasn't a
rise and crash it was actually a
sustained rise in dopamine that took a
very long time up to three hours to come
back down to Baseline which is really
remarkable just through behaviors no
drugs nothing of that sort just through
behaviors we can achieve terrifically
High increases in dopamine that are very
long and sustained in ways that serve us
hearing something that reinforces one's
prior beliefs actually can evoke
dopamine release so the dopamine pathway
is so vulnerable to subjective
interpretation that it actually makes it
such that when we see something or hear
something that validates a belief that
we already have that itself can increase
dopamine release as we start to engage
with something more and more and what we
say about it and what we encourage
ourselves to think about it has a
profound impact on its rewarding or
non-rewarding properties now it's not
simply the case that you can lie to
yourself and you can tell yourself of
something and when you don't really love
it and it will increase dopamine but
what's been found over and over again is
that if people Journal about something
where they practice some form of
appreciation for something or they think
of some aspect of something that they
enjoy the amount of dopamine that that
behavior will evoke tends to go up so
for people that hate exercise you can
think about some aspect of exercise that
you really enjoy I know this is a hard
one for many people but I do invite you
to try removing multiple sources of
dopamine release or what used to be
multiple sources of dopamine release
from activities that you want to
continue to enjoy or that you want to
enjoy more layering together multiple
things substances and activities that
lead to Big increases in dopamine
actually can create pretty severe issues
with motivation and energy right after
those experiences and even a couple days
later so I'm not saying that people
shouldn't take the occasional
pre-workout if that's your thing or
drink a cup of coffee or two before
working out now and again but if you do
it too often what you'll find is that
your capacity to release dopamine and
your level of motivation and drive and
energy overall will take a serious hit
oxytocin and social connection is
actually directly stimulating the
dopamine pathway social connections
close social Connections in particular
that evoke oxytocin release so those are
romantic type those are parent child
type those are friendship related and
those can even be just friends at a
distance related right it doesn't
actually require skin contact to get
oxytocin release but oxytocin release is
Central to stimulating the dopamine
Pathways so the take-home message there
is quite simple engage in pursue quality
healthy social interactions
foreign